hello we don't know whether you've come
here because of chat GPT or because you
want to know about research on chatbots
in general these days then let us tell
you how we came across the idea of
making this video a while ago I was
reading this incredible paper from
deepmind proposing a new chatbot called
Sparrow while we were sitting on this
paper and planning the video here it was
the mighty Chachi pity from openai
changed the landscape of the internet
how exactly you can see in plenty other
YouTube videos we focus on the research
here but disappointingly cha GPT did not
come with an extra paper release on the
other hand Sparrow from deepmind has a
paper but they don't let us play with
the model
and now that everybody's interest is
peaked around chatbots we really really
want to discuss Sparrow especially since
it was trained very much like chat GPT
but with even more objectives because it
can follow explicit rules and can make
Google searches to provide evidence for
its answers since chatgpt did not do
such a good job at telling me what to
say to you in this video Miss Coffee
Bean will give her best shot at
explaining chat GPD from openai and
Sparrow from deepmind and make a
comparison but first let's thank Co here
for sponsoring today's video since
you're watching this video we assume you
already heard about the incredible
advancements of natural language
processing maybe you thought of
including the latest and greatest large
language models into your applications
well then cohere is the right thing for
you it lets you use extremely capable
language model used to let them classify
text for you or let them generate
documents does this sound complicated
fear not because it is not at all
complicated coher's specialty is to take
the finest Transformer based models like
GPT and Bert and let them do the heavy
work for you under the hood
and all you need to do is to write these
few lines of codes to start generating
text you don't even need machine
learning skills to use cohere just
install it with Pippin starco here and
you are ready to go in Python so what
are you waiting for sign up to cohere
and start exploring it they have a very
generous free premium developer tier so
no credits are needed users bear no
costs until they go to production you
can sign up with this link also posted
in the video description below now back
to our chatbots let's get a thing out of
the way how do chatbots like chat GPT
work they are based on language models
which is just a fancy neural network
that can do fancy autocomplete language
models predict next probable words given
previous words even before the user
starts conversing with chatbots like
Sparrow or chatgpt they already we have
an input the so-called prompt which is
basically a description of the
conversational Persona given by the
programmers this prompt increases the
probability that the next words the
language model will spit out are in line
with this Persona so if you're in this
prompt we have the word helpful then
most likely the model will predict next
words that match this description and
will not start using swear words as
easily okay so how does this language
model Converse after this input prompt
which is hidden from you in chat gpt's
interface it is your turn to ask it a
question then given your question and
the Persona description it delivers an
answer then you say something again it
reads the prompt and your first question
it's answer your second question and
based on this it continues to say likely
words that come after this whole history
and this goes on and on which each
iteration from your side in the model's
response you make the model's input
longer and longer the magic thing about
these large language models behind chair
GPT is that they are super fancy
autocompletes that can pick up patterns
for instance if you prompt them with
descriptions and examples that tell them
about an HTML alternative called hbml
they start to pick up the pattern and
the most likely words following your
examples are the correct solution to the
things you just entered with hyper
ability this is called in context view
shot learning in context because it is
not like the model's parameter updates
through learning in the classical sense
of weight optimization it is just that
the input already has a pattern in it
that elicits correct answers from the
model making it seem like it has learned
something that the model itself does not
update becomes clear when we see that
this whole history of conversation and
all things the model learned from you is
gone when you or somebody else opens
another conversation with the chatbot
and the input is now gone and the model
works just with the prompt and not with
the things you had previously conversed
with it or other people did in this new
conversation the history starts a new so
it's not like the model learns anything
from past sessions of conversations or
from other users
now maybe we want to know how Chachi PT
from openai Works chat GPT itself does
not have a paper explaining it but it
has a blog post here we find out that it
is a sibling of instruct GPT and it was
trained similarly to instruct GPT which
has a paper from which we find out that
it works very much like Sparrow from
deepmind and in this video we would
rather present the sparrow paper since
it came later and is a bit more
comprehensive and you'll see why at the
end of the video we will highlight the
differences between sparrow and instruct
GPT so therefore as much as we know
about chat GPT so far
so Sparrow is deepmind's version for a
chatbot interestingly the sparrow paper
never uses the word chatbot and maybe it
has something to do with the fact that
for a long while it was out of fashion
to use the term since research in
chatbots was hyped starting with Eliza
in the 1960s and it failed to deliver
onto its promises so research building
chatbots such as deepmind here with
Sparrow preferred to use another term
like dialogue agent or terms like
dialogue system or conversational AI
it is relieving to see that openai makes
the word chatbot fashionable Again by
naming their model chat GPT and look
they even use the word chatbot in their
blog post once
we think it is a PT Deep Mind did not
release Sparrow or at least gave access
to users to interact with the model like
open AI does with chat GPT especially
since we find the sparrow method its
motivation and paper really cool why did
this team of researchers think about
building Sparrow in the first place
their motivation was that language
models when prompted to behave like
chatbots tend to say inappropriate
things including sexist or racist
statements and they tend to be
opinionated the language model just
doing its thing of predicting next
probable words to what was just being
said does not have the means of knowing
whether it is offending somebody so the
idea with Sparrow is what if we could
Define a set of rules and fine-tune the
language model to follow the rules well
this sounds easy it is quite hard to
convince a language model to follow
rules and the author's solution here
involves human feedback at a smaller
scale about a model following or
breaking rules
then training classifiers that will
mimic human feedback at a larger scale
and then fine-tuning the language model
with reinforcement learning to follow
the feedback of the classifiers and
since the classifiers reflect the human
feedback and the human feedback tells us
something about the model following the
rules or not we should have convinced
the language model to follow rules in
the end and this seems complicated so
how to do this more exactly the authors
built Sparrow by fine tuning chinchilla
they're 70 billion parameter language
model that already has great
capabilities at producing high quality
text and solving natural language
understanding tasks to make it a chatbot
or a dialogue agent the authors use this
prompt to convince it to take the
conversational Persona of a recite
highly knowledgeable and intelligent AI
assistant they give it its name Sparrow
in the prompt and describe what the user
should expect from the model and also
have an example conversation now
following this prompt the user can type
in a question or another conversation
starter and chinchilla will take in the
prompt the user's question and then give
the answer but Sparrow can do something
more than just Converse which is provide
evidence for the answers it gives to
achieve this the authors do a specific
update to Sparrow's prompt we have two
more participants in the conversation
namely the search query and the search
results the search query is basically
also a sparrow Persona where the
language model generates a search query
based on what was said in the
conversation so far and the search
results is basically a call to Google
search and provides a short preview and
link to the result
so now this whole thing containing the
description for Sparrow example user
inputs and search queries and search
results are the prompt which Sparrow
always has as input and generates
answers with
now we come to the part where the
authors make Sparrow also follow rules
first the authors come up with 23 rules
the rules roughly cover three categories
for making Sparrow more helpful correct
and harmless of course this list is not
exhaustive as the authors themselves
admit one could and should come up with
more rules and apply the whole strategy
we are describing here on the additional
rules now to make Sparrow follow these
rules the authors let it talk without it
knowing about these rules in human
annotate how well it does on different
aspects they tell which rules are
violated and whether it should search
the internet to provide evidence and in
case it provided evidence whether it was
good
humans are also given an adversarial
setting where they try their best to
break the model and make it violate the
rules here in a sense the humans are
encouraged to get the worst from the
model and this is valuable training data
for fine-tuning sparrows since the new
iteration of the model should avoid the
worst of the last iteration so this is
the human annotation stage where humans
give feedback on how Sparrow is
performing and since Sparrow at this
stage is just a chinchilla language
model prompted for conversation it
should not do that good now the authors
take the human generated adaptations to
train a neural network to classify how
probable it is for a human to like the
answer that's Sparrow produced they
train another classifier to say whether
a response is likely to break a rule or
not
these classifiers are super useful
because now the authors can train
sparrow with them for each answer
Sparrow produces during training a
classifier can extremely quickly
estimate the human feedback for it
asking humans during training for every
example to give feedback would make
training last forever so the authors use
these classifiers instead so the authors
froze the last 64 layers of chinchilla
and fine-tuned the last 16 layers with
reinforcement learning taking the output
scores of the classifiers enforcing the
model to have low scores on rule
violation and high scores for the
estimate of a human to appreciate the
answer for training the authors use the
data set consisting of questions and
answers from them explain me like I'm 5
data set also conversations from the
human annotators and the generations of
Sparrow's last iteration because why not
apply this strategy in more state Pages
until Sparrow becomes better and better
at following rules and searching the
internet to provide evidence
during inference with the last iteration
of sparrow to get the best answer from
the model the authors let Sparrow
generate multiple answers and give to
the user the answer that ranks best
given the outputs of the classifiers
okay how much better did chinchilla get
after all this heavy lifting involving
human annotation and reinforcement
learning to become Sparrow well humans
say that chinchilla delivers answers
that are plausible 61 of the time while
Sparrow's answers are plausible and
supported by evidence 78 percent of the
time this looks good chinchilla breaks
rules 20 of the time while Sparrow only
8 percent of the time but what I love
about this Sparrow paper is the
extensive evaluation of the models
surprisingly fine-tuning chinchilla to
become Sparrow reinforced some of the
language models stereotypes just to give
you one example this course of sparrow
are worse on the vinogender data
measuring bias towards gender than for
the Baseline chinchilla model
now we know about Sparrow and let's
highlight its differences to chat GPT
first Sparrow was prompted and trained
to deliver evidence for its answers when
needed by searching the internet and
providing the user with the link chat
GPT cannot do that chatgpt is also a
prompted language model based on GPT 3.5
it was also trained through fine tuning
on conversations provided by humans so
humans rank the language model's
responses and this data is used to train
a classifier modeling how a human would
rank chat gpd's answer much like with
Sparrow and fine-tuning with
reinforcement learning uses this
information provided by the model for
estimating a human in the loop and
therefore trains to provide better
answers
butcher GPT misses one very interesting
component that Sparrow has Sparrow also
has training from a classifier trained
on human annotation telling it how well
it can follow a set of rules so in a
sense chatgpt is like Sparrow but
without the capability of searching for
evidence and without rule following
which makes it a bit underwhelming hey
Miss Coffee Bean maybe Sparrow's
conception was more far-sighted than
chat gpts but at least we have access to
chat GPT and can play with it regarding
Sparrow we can only look at the paper
and dream to play with the model
what the world we have models without
detailed papers and we have detailed
papers without model releases should we
even start dreaming about model weights
and code releases
we hope you enjoyed our overview about
chatbots these days and we hope to see
you next time
[Music]